o psol já vende mais o vídeo e hoje vai
ensinar como fazer uma bomba de quase
por você usar e quando volta lá casa
variar ou então para quando vocês forem
executar os pais uma casa para outra uma
vez que ela é portátil e isso então
vamos cruzada
a primeira coisa que eu fiz foi colocar
o suporte para uma bateria de 9 volts no
pedaço de madeira com preço de uma loja
específica para eletrônica mas se vocês
não tiverem podem ser de montar um
brinquedo antigo vai ter e isso suporta
depois prendido um dos fios é um clico e
usa um parafuso para prender desta forma
para que o clima ficar ligeiramente
acima do nível da maneira mais ou menos
de 0,5 centímetro
agora usando a minha justificou vou
tirar esta particular de um lado e do
outro da lata casas estejam crianças
peçam ajuda o outro e claro devem usar
óculos de proteção
não tem portanto que fique bem para não
atrapalhar depois organizar uma lixa se
quiserem para tirar essas barbies
agora vou tirar esta parte a ventilação
de uma máscara e vou colocar num dos
lados da lata
isto porque tem uma membrana que permita
o fluxo só numa direção
ou seja permite que o ar entra na lata
mas não permite que eu saia quando o
fluxo em contrário
agora vou colar usando bastante cola
quente
é muito importante que isso fique bem
preso eo garçom circo pela membrana e
não à volta dessa parte do plástico
portanto vocês ponham cobro duas vezes
agora vou usar um balão vou cortar no
estado
vou colocar na outra partida lado é
importante que este ficasse um pouco
largo no senhor não muito justo para que
haja movimento e não cria muita atenção
no motor ter esta partida tanto podem
deixar como estava antes mas vou deixar
assim porque aí fica mais bonita
fiz um edifício numa das extremidades um
picolé e depois cortei com maio
se vocês não tiverem político a lei
podem ser usar um morango
agora colocar cola no maio dos portos a
tampa e prender o projeto lá no maio e
que portanto que fique bem conectado com
a tampa por isso podem pôr mais colo
depois quando a primeira ficar por
juntar o balão a tampa usar uma super
cola nos em cola quente porque ela quer
e depois vai entregar o racha do balão
seguro na posição central até que carlos
hecke precisar agora a dupla da cidadã
eu usei que um clipe de monthey depois
influi a volta do eixo do motor é você
dar mais ou menos mais 45 voltas
é muito importante que o irã fique bem
preso alguns se vocês quiserem fixar
muito bem podem usar uma gota do super
cola na conexão destas duas partes
agora vou colocar é lata por assim
naquela margem e muito importante que
coloque num contacto com o balão para
não estragar o condutor ficou se um
pouco é baixo e não permite a rotação
daquela partida
então eu coloquei alguns pontinhos de
picolé para lhe dar aquela elevação o
número de boletos picolé que vocês forem
usar vai depender claramente o tamanho
do motor e tamanho do tamanho da lada
eu aconselho que você usa esta lata que
eu utilizei porque aquela parte do
respirador é das mais caras é o tamanho
é igual e encaixa perfeitamente nas
latas pequeninas de coca cola
agora eu marquei a posição onde eu vou
colocar o motor
vocês vão lá atesto ver onde é que fica
a circular bairro marco muito por escola
como fiz agora mesmo
agora vou usar aqui cumprindo assim
desta parte da carga de uma caneta e vou
colocar numa hora isso vai permitir que
parte do projeto picoler não fica
contactar contra o eixo do motor e assim
vai haver menos atrito e vai ficar mais
eficiente o sistema em seguida curta
esta parte da frente uma caneta usando
uma serra para metal e cocaína na lata
nesta posição aqui agora faça um corte
bem pequeninos não faça uso muito grande
porque depois vou encaixar o mtur
desta forma vai ocupar da afiada 1º que
vai criar um espaço mas a
para que quando vocês virarem não haja
sim muita folga aí vai ficar assim
perfeitinho e depois para finalizar isso
vocês têm que colocar como a quinta
volta
não posso ficar nem os pacientes entrou
no ar possa escapar e agora para
finalizar temos que conectar os cabos e
terminar é parte do interruptor
eu fiz um instrutor improvisado eo time
é daquelas comprados
só que muitos de vocês não vão ter então
eu decidi fazer este dentro usando o
clipe é bastante rudimentar mas faz a
mesma coisa com um interruptor normal
a escultura que eu tirei um brinquedo
que encontrei caminhando na rua e ela em
doutor eu ter a engrenagem interruptores
suporte da bateria não foi essa aqui mas
tem outro bateria teve um vôo em maio é
e alguns leves basicamente se vocês
quiserem começar nesta coisa da
eletrônica
uma coisa que vocês podem fazer é ir
montando coisas que já não têm utilidade
que estão estragadas e é assim que eu
fazia quando era porque agora que vocês
podem ver isto funciona quando um clipe
contacto no outro
para finalizar é só conectar a maneira
aquela porta caneta e ligar a bomba para
enriquecer um 'spin com água com
oxigênio uma coisa o sal se os pais
tiverem no fundo financia é porque eles
têm oxigênio sofia e se eu estiver aí
pra cima é porque a falta dele e sei só
o segundo do fim espero que tenham
gostado se vocês quiserem ajudar o canal
é só deixar lá e que isso ajuda bastante
na divulgação e na motivação para eu
criar mais conteúdo muito obrigado até a
próxima